hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i thought i
do a quick review of these premium um
headphone cables uh i got a focal elex
uh
headphone to test the second sample and
the owner was kind enough to send me
these uh
add-on accessory cables from a company
called uh
norn audio n-o-r-n-e
audio uh he sent me three of them this
one i think is the most expensive silver
one
uh you can see it like this a very very
soft
supple cable um all three of them are
this is one i think this is could be as
expensive as eight hundred dollars for
this cable
um then there's one that i think is a
mix of copper and silver
uh braided somehow uh
and then uh he got a maybe thrown in
there because
it took a while to get his cables made
and the owner sent him this
cable i think this one's probably about
250
or so he uh
says these cables aren't exactly what's
on the company's website right now but
when i look they're
very very close i actually found three
models that were similar to these
and uh i've listed them i've listed the
model numbers in here on the review that
i did
post last night yeah i don't know how he
pronounces the drug
silver cable and uh and what have you
um they all use you know various types
of cables
in the lights configuration i know some
people pronounce
lights cables as lit's cables uh i grew
up
calling them lights cables i don't know
what the proper german pronunciation is
or
or whether there's variation of how
people pronounce it in different english
speaking countries anyway these cables i
don't know if you've messed with them
they're very lightweight and have a
special twist
and when i used to terminate them back
in the day i used to hate doing that
because they're just they have this
insulation you got burned off and then
you got a terminator maul
and uh of course somebody sits there and
weaves all these cables like this
uh so close cuzing of uh knitting or
crocheting or something
you gotta sit there and wrap these
things and then you gotta
terminate them together and they gotta
sell them properly and hopefully with
some kind of strained relief
in there to get them to work so um as
expensive as they sound to me
it's uh you know for one-off type of
things doesn't sound expensive i know i
couldn't sell this cable to you for two
hundred dollars and be happy sitting
there in my bedroom making these for you
so it's not a question of cost in here
the question is does it do anything
uh electronically uh electrically or
acoustically
um since i recently measured the four
calorie likes uh
uh it was not easy to just put it on and
uh i was surprised how well i was able
to hold the headphones in the fixture
while
unplugging plugging these cables in
because as you do that the
cups can move and just one millimeter
movement can actually change the
frequency response
and let me circle back to that so this
is the frequency response of the stock
cable
uh in green and then these three cables
as you can see they all land on top of
each other
the stock cable from focal is this awful
stiff braided cable that you get
maybe excuse me as a i don't know 10
usb cables come that way i have no idea
why company like focal would sell
premium k
headphones but comes up with this stiff
nonsense so i can see people
from a mechanical point of view wanting
a cable that's as
soft and supple as these are and
certainly something that looks better
than what's there but from frequency
response point of view measured
acoustically meaning
what was going to go to your ears
there's not even a hair out of place
over here
uh it's just incredible how repeatable
the measurements are
and despite the fact that i had to
mechanically plug and unplug things
uh if the headphones had moved just a
hair
it would have made more of a variation
than these cables have so
to give you a sense of how unreasonable
it is to assume that the frequency once
changes
every time you put this thing on your
head and take it off you know you're
putting it on differently and you're
actually causing
frequent response variations that are
measurable but you're probably not even
perceiving that
here we can even measure the effect on
this test
um the headphone measurement system
automatically spits out
distortions as i show for the headphones
and we can see the
different distortion graphs again for
the star cable and blue and then
the other three cables uh on that
and these slide variations that you see
in here this is all
uh just measurement differences there's
noise in the environment and
and run to run variations actually this
is exceptionally good for headphone
measurements
uh the one difference i found was around
120 hertz which is a
double domains frequency of 60hz in us
and it must be radiating from something
around here that i have
lots of electronics on my desk and i was
not paying attention to laying the cable
identically so i just randomly measured
i'm not expecting a difference
and i noticed that the stock cable does
the best excuse me
in this regard and the three premium
cables are actually
slightly worse and picking up that hum
and mains
noise um i set up a custom test
for that where i take these cables and i
have a
transformer that lets me induce uh
electromagnetic field into the
cables and uh i noticed that
all of them pick up some amount uh on
that
and uh it was not conclusive maybe the
stock cable was a little bit less but
it just wasn't conclusive enough so i
don't you know
basically the orientation of the cable
and the source would make it enough more
of a difference than the cable
differences themselves so
this just may be a fluke that the other
cables picked up more mains noise or not
but
it's bad luck for the company that their
cables are the
ones that did worse at least in this one
one test
now acoustic measurements are limited in
their resolution because of the
noise that exists in the environment and
also the limitation of the headphone
itself the headphone
is 1.7 distortion so let's say these
cables have a 0.01
difference it's not going to show up in
here but it is what we hear
it is the application so this is a real
application but to go out of our way and
really focus on the cable itself i
bypass the headphone
so i'm still using the top in a90 as the
uh
source amplifier headphone amplifier but
instead of connecting the other end of
the cable
to a headphone i just hooked it up to my
audio precision analyzer and just
measured electrically what the frequency
response would look like
and you can see in here there's just
absolutely no difference this display is
extremely
zoomed so only quarter of a db down and
quarterly the alps of the entire range
is only half a db even if we had
variations that would fill this graph
it's doubtful that you know you could
hear according to b
difference in frequency response but we
don't even have that we have nothing
really it's just as flat as you can get
there's a slight error
in here in low frequencies that's just a
measurement artifact and
having to average things out to get rid
of noise but
essentially what you're looking at is
the frequency response of the
uh headphone amplifier not the cable the
all cables have wider bandwidth
than the amplifier itself and the
amplifier itself is great by the way
it's quarter of db down at 60 kilohertz
uh on this thing at 20 kilohertz is it's
not even
you know measurable 0.01 db or something
like that
so objectively as the physics would say
as everything about electronics would
say
they're just you know coming out of two
different ways with a headphone without
the headphone
load it just absolutely there's nothing
in here to put
put your finger on or hang your head on
and say hey
you know this cable can change the sound
frequency response
is what dictates tonality how bright
something is how much the mids you're
hearing the bass the impact all that
stuff is in there
and non-linearities show up in in
distortion graphs
and there's just nothing there at all
now i know better than to finish the
review at this point because the other
camp immediately says wow he didn't
listen
well okay well listen but how do you do
an a b test of cables you've got to
put the headphone on then you can't even
plug them in blind
really speaking gotta take them off to
be able to see the holes to plug in the
cable and put it back on
and then plug it in and play the same
music again
by then a minute has gone by and uh
and you put the headphone on differently
every time anyway
so no way to from an objective and
proper way of doing control testing can
this be valid because there's just too
much interruption there
and but we did the test anyway when i
said we
my son is in his 20s and it's got a much
better sensitivity his first level
than that i do and neither one of us
could hear a difference
uh on that thing uh now obviously people
say they hear night and day difference
or they hear
i don't know some level of difference
it's the standard explanation i've given
in the past
and that your brain listens differently
you change
cables and you listen differently you
may think it sounds better you may think
it sounds worse you absolutely hear a
difference
because you're focusing differently on
music you're not a machine
you're not like my measurement gear and
every time you apply yourself you apply
yourself differently
that's why we do the test blind um when
you don't know something's changed or
not
and then we can see statistically
whether you were just coming up with
these things
and the same thing would apply to both
cables if we did it blind
but when you do the test cited then you
know what you're switching and what have
you
and you just can't arrive at any kind of
reliable
conclusion that there is a difference
your brain's ability to manufacture
differences
is probably a hundred to a thousand
times more than this cable possibly
could even if it had a difference
and but there isn't it's just uh you
know they
they just sounded the same i mean
there's i don't know what else to tell
you
the physics say that the electronics say
the theory says that the research says
that measurements say that
every arrow points to any statement of
audible difference
to be wrong or at best hugely unlikely
the fact that somebody ad hoc says oh i
can hear it it's like
great go ahead and do a blind test where
you have somebody put the
headphones on you without you seeing
them and have them change the cables
behind you and do that 10 times
see if you get at least 8 out of 10
right until you do that then
you're just letting your eyes and your
state of mind and
and perception guide you as opposed to
real truth on these things
now there's no denying that these cables
feel better i didn't try to wear them
long term but just touching them you
want to sort of
play with them and wrap up they feel
nice and
they seem well built uh because you're
braiding so many cables
uh on this thing and if they give you
joy in having them and you can get them
custom lengths and what have you
get it as i said at the outset i don't
think this person's
you know gouging people on this thing i
don't know how much silver cables cost
and what have you but i know that
sitting there in your home and
putting up at the misery of making
cables is not fun and then dealing with
customers and selling them and
taking returns and building and shipping
all that stuff so
personally i don't have an issue with
the cost or the business model and i
understand my understanding that this
person lives in silicon valley hugely
expensive place to live and and try to
pay mortgage payments and get some food
so
uh it's not a religion i have against
companies like this and
in case of focal if i own those
headphones the standard stock cord would
drive me nuts and i would get something
else
but you know if you want to go with this
company's cables i would get the
cheapest ones you can and 200
ones are you know same connectors at
each end and
they look fine too although i don't know
if i like this
color but otherwise they're fine so
um just you know objectively we test
this stuff so that when somebody says
how do you know they don't sound
different well we've we've tried you
know we've tried it our way
we tried it their way with listening
tests and there's no difference now if
you want to say that i don't hear as
well
i'm happy to pass a challenge that
for both of us to take on what your
ability is to hear the differences
and that starts with you first showing
blind that you can tell the difference
is that easy and that obvious just don't
look when you uh
tell us which is which and see where you
are
you know it's a good opportunity to get
educated on these things and if you're
on the fence and
you know you haven't dived into this
topic i highly encourage you to look at
results like this
and know that everything we know about
science and engineering points to the
results that i have to be true
but we still spend the energy and time
and expense of shipping these cables
back and forth
just to have some hard data behind our
opinion so that
we don't just have you know my word we
have my word then we have data we have
research
the other side wants to counter this
then they need to go beyond their work
they gotta have their research
okay hope you found some of this useful
and
i'll see you in a future video bye